hello good morning and welcome to safety
Ridge on Sunday it's the week of local
elections which means politics is even
more intense than usual everything at
the minute is heightened and today we
have an exclusive interview with a man
who wants to be the next prime minister
kirstalmer and I have to say at some
point the conversation does get quite
intense it's definitely worth a watch
the big political issue of the week is
voters in England prepare to go to the
polls is strikes and nurses are walking
out from 8pm and what's expected to be
the most disruptive NHS strike so far
but who will household responsible
well on the program this morning in just
a moment we're going to hear from the
leader of the labor party Kia starmer
and for the government we are speaking
this morning to the transport secretary
Mark Harper
as nurses start that new strike over the
bank holiday I'm going to be joined by
the General Secretary of the Royal
College of Nursing Pat Cullen
and with those local elections just days
away now we're going to be joined live
by Zach Polanski he is of the Green
Party
plus artificial intelligence is already
shaping our world and it's likely to
have a huge influence on our lives and
politics in the future on the program
today we're going to be talking to the
British computer scientist Stuart
Russell
[Music]
hello good morning well today we are
going to be starting by hearing from the
leader of the labor party
now general election is potentially just
a year or so away when the labor leader
will be hoping he can turn the very
solid poll leads of recent months into a
House of Commons majority but there is
still a long way to go and the local
elections are a really important test I
joined Zakir on the campaign Trail in
Derby where you can see him there
shaking hands with some of these staff
at the Royal Crown Derby Pottery they're
making a coronation at plates in
particular ahead of that coronation we
sat down to talk in the UNESCO world
heritage listed site of what is thought
to be the world's first mechanized
Factory
thank you very much for being on the
program and we're here on the local
election campaign trail with you so what
does the good night look like then for
labor next week well we're running a
very positive campaign we've got a
really good set of candidates
um and we're hoping to make progress and
I'm humble about this I know we've got
to earn every vote but we do want to
make progress
the cycle is the cycle four-year cycle
from May 2019 as you know so that means
it's quite hard for us because in May
2019 if you cast your mind back we had
Theresa May as prime minister and the
local election results for the Tory
party back in 2019 were the second worst
in their history and Theresa May had to
go out after those elections and
apologized for candidates because the
results were so appalling so I think for
the conservative party the Baseline is
on the floor
and they should be making gains and if
they don't if they can't make gains on
that awful set of results then I think
there are serious questions as to
whether Rishi sunak is going backwards
in fact in terms of their electoral
prospects so it's a it's a difficult
cycle because you know of that Baseline
but I think really the question will be
why aren't the tour is making pretty
significant gains so you're seriously
saying the conservatives should be
making significant gains right well in
2019 that was their second worst set of
results ever and Theresa May I mean as I
say apologize to Canada I think three
weeks later she was challenged for the
leadership resigned and that was it was
effectively those results I mean the
concert was saying we should be
expecting a thousand losses well if they
are I find that astonishing if they're
saying that uh they're going to go below
their second worst set of results in
these elections then
um they truly are going backwards but
that I think is just expectation
Management on their part they ought to
be made making games significant gains
the base law Baseline for them is on the
floor and so this will raise questions
about whether they're going backwards in
fact you
pretty comfortable lead in the polls for
a while now it's starting to narrow a
little bit though isn't it are you
worried about the trajectory well I've
set my stall out in 2020 when I became
leader of the labor party picked us up
from the worst general election results
since 1935 and said we must take
ourselves from there into a labor
government so looking at that and the
question I ask myself is are we making
Pro progress on that trajectory and then
the answer that is yes we've changed the
party but the polls are narrowing so
that's my question I guess are you still
making progress yes I mean the polls
that we saw in the Autumn of last year
in the middle of the mini budget we're
never going to last I think everybody
accepted that but the real question is
are we making progress from that
terrible result in 2019 towards the next
general election and I'm pleased in the
sense that
um the question the challenge I get now
is not the challenge I got when I took
over which is it's impossible so many
people shook me by the hand when I
became leader labor party good luck here
but you'll never turn it around in a
five-year Parliament it's not possible
for labor to go from that to win the
challenge now is why aren't you further
ahead well that shows we've made
progress we've changed the party the
I'll analyze these results as I always
do against the underlying constituencies
as we head into the general election of
2024 in all probability okay and I want
to talk to you about a few of the kind
of big issues now
um NASA strikes a huge issue for so many
people lots of anxiety and they're
striking without exemptions for
emergency care so no a e maternity
Cancer Care are they wrong to do that I
don't want these strikes to go ahead I
don't think anybody does I don't think
the nurses do but I do think the
government has made a complete mess of
the negotiation the question is should
nurses be striking without exemptions
for emergency care well I don't want to
see the strikes go ahead so they're
wrong to do that I don't want to see the
strikes go ahead but the way to avoid
exemptions that's what I'm asking about
specifically the way to avoid strikes is
to get them the room with the nurses and
to resolve these issues now if you
remember Before Christmas the RCN said
to the government if you get into the
room with us and negotiate about pay we
won't go on strike at all
they've got an offer that they put to
their members the government then sat it
out for week after week after week and
they caused the situation now where
we're in a real mess and the government
needs to learn that lesson get in the
room negotiate this compromise and get
on with it and you know nobody but
nobody wants to strikes in nursing in
hospitals in Railway or anywhere else I
can quite understand
the pressures bearing down on nurses and
doctors and those who work on the
railways because wages have been
stagnant for over a decade living
standards haven't gone up and bills have
gone up everywhere because there's an
underlying structural problem here which
is that we haven't grown the economy the
economy has had no effective growth for
13 years that is an utter failure of
this government that is the heart of
these strikes the cost of living crisis
of course we've had you train of course
we've had covered but our country is
faring worse than other countries and
there's a reason for that and it's the
13 years of failure I'm still slightly
unclear if I'm honest about whether or
not you think it is acceptable for
nurses to strike without exemptions
um at pmqs last week you said either the
Prime Minister doesn't use the same
Public Services as the rest of us or he
simply can't see the damage what do you
mean it doesn't use the same Public
Services as the rest of us I think if
the prime minister or other Tories
saw firsthand
the way our NHS is operating they would
better understand just how damaged it is
what do you mean by that though I'm just
trying are you basically saying he's too
wealthy to use public services in the
same way as others is that what you're
trying to say I'm saying is how to touch
that he doesn't know what's happening in
the everyday lives of very many millions
you're saying he doesn't use the same
Public Services what do you mean well I
mean he's out of touch talk to anybody
who's trying to get an appointment with
the GP that eight o'clock call they know
how hard it is they know the Health
Service is broken anybody in a waiting
list anybody actually going into a e my
wife works in the NHS this is a constant
discussion I say to her the NHS is on
its knees she says to me no it's not
it's on its face and that is the result
of 13 years of neglect and
um when I look at what's happened to our
NHS it breaks my heart that it's been
allowed to get into this state which is
why we've set out that one of our
missions if we do have the privilege of
winning the next election will be to you
know build an NHS for the future we've
got to fix the NHS and you know it's the
same with the cost of living crisis the
Prime Minister sort of smiles his way
through the cost of living crisis
without understanding the real impact I
was in Ripley and near Derby this
morning talking to people in the local
co-op in the cafe and it's the same
story across all of these local lectures
people saying to me I go around the
supermarket I pick things up and then I
put them back down again I turn my
heating on for a short period of the
morning but not otherwise because even
though it's cold I can't afford to pay
the bills pensioners who feel that you
know they've put in all their lives but
now when they want just a bit of comfort
they can't make ends meet I don't think
I don't think the Prime Minister
understands I don't think I mean this
morning people saying to me I don't
think he understands what I'm actually
the way my life is and I think that's a
real problem because a question in
politics is who have you got in your
mind's eye when you make your decisions
and I've got in mind mines either people
I was talking to this morning I think
he's got in his Mind's Eye the richest
one percent because it's that richest
one percent that he gave a tax break to
I'm Keen to talk a bit more about
Richard Cena later but while we're
talking about public services you've got
an announcement on house building are
you going to bring back mandatory house
building targets yes and I'll tell you
for why because having your own house
the it is hugely important for security
so I mean I know this when I was growing
up my dad was a tool maker my mum was a
nurse we didn't have a lot of money but
we had our own house and that's a sense
of security and that's why people dream
aspire to have their own house home
ownership and that dream has been killed
by the Prime Minister because he took
down the targets he himself has admitted
that he did it because he was giving in
to his own members that shows a
fundamental weakness and it's he who
accepts he gave in to them and he's
killed that dream of home ownership
these targets were in place until late
last year there weren't enough houses
being built then either were that if you
really want to transform the housing
market you have to take on overall local
contents right are you prepared to take
on the nimbies yes so we need to get the
target back
to show strength and build out of the
damage that the Prime Minister has
inflicted on the country but we also
need I think to take on the planning
laws make sure that local authorities
have greater power to decide whether
housing will be in their patch and to
ensure that we have the vehicles for
delivery you know Housing and
Development corporations that are
actually a vehicle to delivery so yes we
would have the ambition to do that but
at the moment I can't emphasize enough
this is I was up in Preston yesterday
with barretts and they were saying the
market for first-time buyers has just
gone through the roof it's Fallen away
as a joint result of the Kamikaze mini
budget which threat mortgages and
mortgage deals through the roof so it's
now unaffordable and the taking down of
targets which means less housing less
affordable housing so people are Out Of
Reach and they are then forced to
continue in high rent you know rental
accommodation Which is far too high and
you know generation rent rent in a
census is being held in a headlock by
this government
um now normally in interviews this
program I try and kind of look forward
but I just want to go back to something
if I may because I think it's quite
important and if I'm being honest I
don't feel like you've been properly
kind of questions about it so at the
beginning of April labor published an
attack ad which had a picture of Rishi
sunak and it said do you think adults
convicted of sexually assaulting
children should go to prison where she
seen that doesn't now you've since said
that you stand by every word of that
right so do you care starmer believe
that rishis United thinks that pedophile
should not go to jail is that what
you're saying the figures speak for
themselves no I'm not talking about the
figures because we're talking about what
it says here in the ad do you think
adults convicting a convicted of
sexually assaulting children should go
to prison rushy soon that doesn't yeah
is that what you think
I think if he did think they should go
to prisoner do something about it so you
don't think he thinks Peter Paul should
go to prison is that what you're
seriously saying I stand by the advert
is that so that's what the advert says
you're is that what you're seriously
saying yes I think that as prime
minister you take responsibility for
what happens in your criminal justice
system he is not taking responsibility
for it and this idea that somehow you
can ship in a new prime minister we've
had five of them now in the last 13
years and that somehow he doesn't bear
responsibility they have broken our
criminal justice system so it is
unforgivable
do you take personal responsibility then
for every child abuser who escaped
prison while were you a director of
public prosecutions I take full
responsibility for every decision of the
crown prosecution
responsibility I'll tell you how that
worked when I was director of public
prosecutions it meant that when we
succeeded in some very important
prosecutions as we did there was a an
attempt to bring down seven planes
across the Atlantic at the same time a
massive terrorist operation we
prosecuted that successfully got a
awards for that and I took the credit
for that on behalf of the organization
where we got it wrong I carried the can
and what that meant to me carrying the
can was identifying what the problem was
and what we needed to fix it so when I
carried the can I looked at the problem
I analyzed what had gone wrong rolled up
my sleeves and fixed it
from the government you're accepting
they would have a completely different
system you're accepting then that things
went wrong under your watch right and
I'm not going to get into what they were
because I don't want to engage in it if
I'm being completely honest
um but that doesn't mean that you don't
think that rapists should go to jail
does it it means that you just take a
responsibility for it that's what you're
saying in this ad well you know the
question in a sense has to be put to the
Prime Minister which is if he contests
this why is he not doing something about
it and fixing the situation but which is
the approach I took you take the
plaudits when the organization does very
well which the crown prosecution service
did a lot under my watch but if
something does go wrong you analyze
what's the problem and you fix it
under the conservatives four thousand
five hundred adults convicted of
sexually assaulting children under 16
said no prison time now that's figures
from the last 13 years of conservative
government I mean CNET wasn't even an MP
for five of those let alone having any
responsibility for the justice system
well this idea that 13 years of
doesn't think pedophile should go to
jail that's what's saying we've had 13
years of failure
um we've had 13 years in which we've had
five prime ministers the idea that you
can just slot in a new prime minister
and suddenly the Slate is wipe clear
they have no responsibility he is taking
that political party into the next
general election and his his message
will be to the country notwithstanding
the failure now 13 years probably 14 by
the time we get to the next general
election give me and us another five
years that is the biggest risk to our
country five more years of this failure
and one of the things we're talking
about this morning with people in the
court was do you feel any better off is
anything working better after 13 years
the risk in this country is not changed
to a labor party it will clear up the
mess and take us forward the risk is
carrying on with five more years of this
failure we know far-right groups have
weaponized the sexual abuse abuse
committed by Asian grooming gangs right
a very small minority of Asians now your
attacker had accuses the first ever
British Asian prime minister of not
thinking child sex abusers to go to
prison is it racist no there's a huge
um you know under analysis of the
figures here and I looked at this when I
was director of public prosecutions the
vast majority of child sexual offenses
are not uh by uh people of Asian origin
or anything else absolutely so it's not
a racist advert then no it's not of
course it's not okay
um now I'm Keen to uh move on to talk
about other things as well Richard Sharp
has resigned as the chairman of the uh
BBC this crisis in part caused because
some people would feel that the
government is effectively trying to get
an ally into that job do you think that
that power to appoint people to these
kind of roles should be taken out of
government hands yes I think it'd be far
better if it was an independent process
and what you've got is yet another
example of contact with the with those
at the top of the Tory party leading to
this sort of outcome this resignation is
only the latest of a series of issues
like this where there's been that
contamination at the top of the Tory
party so yes we need to do something
about it it has done damage to the BBC
impartiality is that well it's certainly
done damage the reputation of the BBC so
we would have an independent process
look at what that process looks like to
ensure that those sorts of mistakes
can't be those sorts of associations
wouldn't be possible under a labor
government but we also need to clean up
politics because you know we've had
issue after issue where there's sleaze
there's suggestions of contracts being
awarded to people who know each other in
the conservative party we've got to end
that sort of politics
um I'm interested as well in your you
said that it's done damage the
reputation of the BBC I'm interested in
your wider view of the UK media as well
and you obviously um brought convictions
towards journalists of phone hacking and
also payments public officials when you
director of public prosecutions would
you like to see a levison too well there
are outstanding issues there although a
lot of time has passed since leverson
won
um so you know I think there are still
issues but you know let me be clear I'm
setting out the priorities of the next
Labor government in the missions that
I'm setting out and at the moment my
absolute focus is on those five missions
which is you know grow our economy the
fastest sustained growth in the G7
making sure that we can power towards
clean energy by 2030 Safe Streets better
opportunities for everybody and so those
those missions are what drives me
forward so you know are there still
issues yes there are but I'll be clear
we will be a priorities-led government
with an absolute focus on the missions
that I've set out so at the minute not a
priority well the the first priority is
going to have to be growing the economy
the sink the highest sustained growth in
the G7 is what we want to go for and
that is important because you know we
often have arguments about tax and spend
the best way to have better public
services to have our businesses thriving
is to grow our economy and that's will
be the single focus of an incoming labor
government now just uh wrapping up
you're an Arsenal fan yes what's more
likely Arsenal we're in the Premier
League or you win in the election oh
are having gone through what we went
through in the game with Man City the
other night then I'm afraid I think uh
for this year it's over for Arsenal but
it's a brilliant squad for the future so
you're not going to chat with a big lead
then well look you know there's a lesson
there because at the beginning of every
season people confidently predict who's
going to win the league in the end it
comes to April before it really is
decided there's a lesson in there for
politics we've got to fight all the way
into the next election got a fight like
we're Five Points behind and we've got
to make our positive case for the
electorate thank you very much thank you
apologies to any also fans I am allowed
to say uh make a joke about choking with
a big lead as a Sheffield Wednesday fan
if you have any idea about what's
happening in League one that was the
labor leader Kirsten who was talking to
me in Derby we can get the view now from
the government as the local election so
also of course a crucial test for Rishi
sunac six months or so into his
leadership just a few moments ago I
spoke to the transport secretary Mark
Harper
and thank you very much for being on the
program this morning we just heard from
Kirsten we're in the interview he I
asked him if he really believes that
Rishi CNAC doesn't think pedophiles
should go to prison as in the attack ad
that labor put out and he says yes
what's your reaction to that well I
think first of all I think people listen
to that all think that's nonsense the
you judge people I think in politics by
what they do people remember it wasn't
that long ago that the prime ministers
said of a task force specifically to
deal with one aspect of that issue which
is to deal with grooming gangs which is
a subject the labor doesn't even want to
talk about so I think if people judge
the prime minister's actions they'll see
that the substance of that ad was
nonsense I think the second aspect is I
think politics also ought to be focused
on you know what people actually do and
the policies they set out and I think
personal attacks are not very helpful
many many politicians you know
particularly female politicians have to
put up with a lot of abuse online abuse
and I think all all people in leadership
positions should be trying to conduct
politics I think with a slightly
different tone so I think it's very
disappointing approach from him but I
don't actually think the public will
will buy it actually and I guess
Kirsten's argument is that look it's
right to focus on the number of people
who have been let off for some of these
really serious crimes and the
conservative's record on crime over the
last 13 years well look it's fair to
focus on policy but that isn't what
they're doing in the attack ads and
actually we've got very tough laws on
those serious offenses but in the end
sentences are set by judges
um you know no no one's I don't think
anyone's turning around pretending that
KIA storm was responsible for all of
those sentences that took place when he
was a member of the sentencing Council
and actually responsible for setting
those rules I mean he does take
responsibility for that at least well
yeah he might say that but the fact is
if he's going to apply his own argument
then he has to say that he's guilty of
the same things as he's accusing the
prime minister of I just don't think
it's a very good way to conduct politics
you should focus on the issues and the
prime ministers demonstrated on this
subject in would he set out the other
week on cracking down on one aspect of
it which is on grooming gangs and he's
actually very tough on it and I think
that's how people will judge him you
talk a bit about the tone in politics
and what MPS are subjected to and it
just make me think about the story about
Stella Christie the labor MP where she
completely incredibly was contacted by
Social Services after someone said that
her children should be taken away
because of her views on men what's your
reaction to that well I think it's
terrible I think look we all disagree
with each other I don't always agree
with Stella about some of the campaigns
she runs but I think the treatment that
she's had to put up with is terrible the
treatment that many colleagues on my
side of the house have to put up with is
terrible I think all MPS of all parties
have to put are putting up with a lot
and they shouldn't have to people in
politics you know we should all be able
to disagree uh have robust disagreements
but it shouldn't descend into people's
um families being attacked or their
personal lives being attacked I don't
think that's the right way to conduct
politics do you think Social Services
have questions to answer
well I don't know the specifics of that
case but I don't think people who are
attacked because of the job they do
um should have their personal lives
damaged in that way so I think you know
whoever's been involved in this should
look at the facts of the case and I
think it's clearly appalling
connections uh fast approaching uh
Kirsten says you should be making gains
the conservatives should be putting on
seats all of a dad on said last week
that he expects you to lose a thousand
seats so what is going on there is the
truth somewhere in the middle well look
we're obviously fighting very hard for
every vote but I mean I think look if
you look at the independent commentators
the independent experts in this okay
it's all the very respected ones they're
they're forecasting you know it's not
our forecast they're forecasting that
they think we we might lose a thousand
seats so I mean if people want to judge
things that's sort of what the
independent experts
campaigning for every vote are they
saying that because of how bad the
situation is for your party I mean you
last bought these uh seats in 2019 when
Theresa May as kostama says apologize a
few weeks later resigned and that was
the end of her and that's the Baseline
and you're saying you're going to go
backwards well well no we're not saying
that look we're not well you are saying
that aren't you we're not commentators
we're participants in this process you
know we're going out making our
arguments very strongly and we're going
out knocking on doors fighting for every
vote all I'm saying is if you want to
judge where expectations are if you look
at what the independent experts are
saying they're suggesting they think
we're going to lose a thousand seats
because it's tough at the vote look we
acknowledge is tough on people you know
there's a war going on in Europe we're
recovering from the pandemic inflation
is high that is pushing people's
finances under pressure and so it's
difficult at the moment we've obviously
got very clear plan and one of our our
clear range of the five priorities the
Prime Minister set at is to have
inflation to grow the economy and to cut
debt I think if we can deliver on that
this year things will look much more
promising but you know it is tough at
the moment I think it's very sensible to
acknowledge that but look independent
experts have made their full when they
say they say I just want to pick up on
that because they're not saying that
that's definitely going to happen a
thousand seats it's just in the range of
possibilities right well that's their
forecast look it's not their forecasters
it could be as bad as they're suggesting
that that's what might happen What might
happen not what will happen so I think
it is important to qualify that in the
end politicians are not just cherry pick
the worst case scenario no no I'm just
saying that seems to be where they're
sort of saying is a sort of expectation
politicians though I think since we're
not to get into the forecasting game
we're about trying to persuade every
single person listening to this program
that they should vote conservative
because conservative councils as ever
deliver better services at lower cost
than labor and legal Democrat Council so
that's why people should vote for their
conservative Council candidates uh
nurses go on strike from 8pm we're going
to be speaking to Pat Cullen of the
Royal College of nurses uh shortly uh
what's your message to her well look of
the payoff that was offered to NHS staff
which we think was a fair and reasonable
payoff some of the largest unions in the
NHS their members have accepted that at
pay deal and obviously the health sector
is going to wait formally until Tuesday
when the NHS staff Council which brings
together all of those unions formally
reports back to him but he stands ready
to implement that offer subject to
hearing from them finally so clearly a
lot of members working in the a lot of
workers in the NHS have accepted that
fair and reasonable payoff though and
he'll have to decide after Tuesday's
meeting what the next steps are but look
I'd say to pakka look she I think agreed
that it was a fair and reasonable payoff
for because she and her her executive
recommended it to their members their
members obviously haven't accepted it
and obviously if it's going to cause
disruption in the NHS so I would urge
them to to think again and to do what
the other trade unions in the Health
Service are done which is except what I
think is a fair and reasonable payoff
for reflecting the value that we do
place on hard-working NHS stuff you say
that they should accept it because
others have but the point is I guess the
nurses who worked for the RCN or the
majority of them didn't think it was the
right payoffer and you know if you look
at
um pay pay the nurses gain over the last
decade they have seen really difficult
paid decisions made all the way back
since 2010 the average pay of NHS nurses
falling in real terms by eight percent
by since 22 10 analysis from the London
economics saying that the nurse has paid
a client at twice the rate a private
sector pay you can see why they feel
that they should be given you know a
decent pay rise well they should be
given a decent pay rise and I think
that's what they were offered if you
look at faster inflation if you look at
um last year actually when there was a
public sector pay freeze this
specifically was a pay rise for nurses
to reflect the value that the government
places on them and the pay deal that
they were offered would have given a a
band five nurse so that's an average
nurse over the two years of that pay
dealer I think something in the order of
a five thousand pound pay rise so the
government believes it was a fair and
reasonable pay rise some of the other
staff groups the GMB and Unison have
accepted the pay rise so look the
secretary say well listen to what the
NHS staff Council says on Tuesday but he
stands ready I know to implement the pay
deal that was offered if if that's what
the NHS stealth Council report back on
Tuesday unlike other strikes um
originally there were no exemptions for
emergency care so things like cancer
treatment am the maternity they have now
after some hospitals like Great Ormond
Street
um raised the alarm if you like said
that in some local areas they will
provide cover I our lives at risk over
the next couple of days well I think the
thing that's very difficult here is that
because they haven't agreed any national
exemptions it makes it very difficult
for those individual trusts and the
individual trust managers to put in
place arrangements to deal with those
areas like a e like cancer treatment so
what does that mean are you worried
about lines it clearly does put patients
at risk which is why we urge the the
unions not to go ahead and do the strike
um clearly if if
NHS staff are not working I mean all of
those trusts are going to work really
hard to put in place contingency
Arrangements at local level they'll all
be working with NHS staff to look at the
contingency arrangements and doing their
best but clearly there will be an impact
if nurses don't come to work
give us an update on restaurants as well
if you may
although I I think it's very damaging
that the rail unions are calling strikes
specifically targeting
um the Eurovision song contest I've I've
met with the head of Ukrainian Railways
the Ukrainian Railways have been
specifically targeted by Vladimir Putin
well because they're being killed in
their hundreds and I would have thought
frankly rail workers would have wanted
to stand in solidarity with them rather
than targeting Eurovision song contest
which if you remember it's not our song
contest we're hosting it but we're
hosting it for Ukraine and I think
cynically targeting events the
hard-working working men and women
across the country are spending their
money on to try and attend and targeting
those I think is very cynical there's
been a few do you take a bit of
responsibility for this as well right
because you know Richard Cena says that
he is the great deal maker that's how
he's trying to
portray himself as prime minister these
strikes have been going on for
absolutely months now and look if you
kind of zoom out we have a government
that is effectively the relationship
between the government and the people
who keep this country running has broken
down so the people who you know care for
our sick and Hospital the people who
teach our children the people who drive
the trains do you not take some
responsibility for that as well well
look when I got this job I thought it
was good to reset the relationship I met
all the Trade union leaders I remember
you saying to us and you know it has
because if you look at a lot of the
workers in the rail industry so rmt
workers who work for Network rails so
that thousands of workers who work on
the infrastructure actually they've had
a fair and reasonable payoff for rmt put
it to their members and the members
overwhelmingly accepted it 90 turnout 76
in favor What's Happening Here is that
the rmt executive isn't putting the
third payoff that they've had from the
train operating companies they're
refusing to put it to their members now
my view is if they put it to their
members if you look at what they did on
the network rail pay deal I think their
members would accept it so my call to
the union executive this is not aimed at
the hard-working men and women who work
on the railway their Executives should
put what is a fair and reasonable
payoffer it's very similar to the
network put it to their members let them
decide and not Target the Eurovision
Song Contest in the FA Cup Final hitting
hard-working men and women up and down
the country in this no long running just
be I'm talking about the rail Railways
I'm talking about the schools and
talking about the hospitals is there
something that you think in retrospect
the government should have done
differently well I think the
government's having to deal with two
very difficult things here I'm not
asking about what you have to do with
what should you have done differently
like looking back and being honest what
should the government have done
differently well I think if you look at
the fact that take the NHS which you
were talking about if you take the fact
that actually the biggest trade unions
and their members have accepted that
they haven't done anything wrong I don't
know I'm the last no I'm not saying that
I'm saying anything wrong if you look at
the overall look we can all go back and
look at individual things but if you
look at the over oh no that's what I'm
asking you if you look at the overall
position we've made fair and reasonable
payoff for us they've been accepted Now
by some of the biggest NHS unions and
network rail staff have settled so you
can't name a single thing the
government's done wrong I don't think
that's part of the problem no but I
don't I don't it's not very humble is it
when you're like these these are people
who like on on low-paid jobs many of
them working really hard and and you
can't say a single thing the
government's done wrong well I don't
think it's very I don't think it's very
helpful to just go back over the history
and think what could we have done
differently I'm focused just on what
we're doing going forward I think and by
the way on train drivers they're
actually pretty well paid actually the
average salary of a train driver is 60
000 pounds I've said many of the people
who are going on strike and I'm talking
about nurses I'm talking about ambulance
but of the ones I'm about but the ones
I'm responsible for train drivers get 60
000 pounds a year the pay deals very
easy to pick like the one the one people
the whole group the pay deal they've
been offered would take their average
salary to nearly 65 000 pounds and they
won't even put that payoff to their
members and so my my argument
about 60 000 years no it no it isn't and
I wasn't pretending it was but that
we've made a fair and reasonable
payoffer to NHS staff which has been
accepted by the largest Health unions
the members of the largest Health unions
um and as I said the secretary of state
will get their formal feedback on
Tuesday okay
um we had the last flight out of Saddam
the ceasefire was coming to an end
what will happen to British Nationals
national team may still be in the
country
the the well the evacuation that we've
conducted is the longest and largest
evacuation of any Western Nation we've
taken out the
1888 British Nationals which I think is
a testimony to the hard work of both
those on the ground who've put
themselves at risk and also those
working
um uh HQ to get that evacuation in place
we've now got some staff based at Port
Sudan which is where we're going to
continue providing Consular support for
British Nationals that have chosen to
remain in the country but we we were
very clear with our messaging about the
need to get people out well the
ceasefire was in place you'll have seen
there was an attack on a Turkish
aircraft a couple of days ago
demonstrating that that evacuation was
not without risk and we therefore can't
stay there indefinitely but we were
clear with British citizens about the
need to get to the Airfield to evacuate
and I say we've taken out 1 888 British
Nationals and their dependents which I
think is a testimony to a very
successful evacuation effort and we will
continue providing Consular support from
Port Sudan there's a couple of other
things I was just Keen to get your
Reflections on um of course there's been
a lot of scrutiny about the BBC chairman
who stood down this week and resigned
should that appointment now be taken out
of government hands
the BBC of course is a a publicly
accountable institution funded by
through the license fee effectively by
taxpayers and that's why there's been a
long-standing Arrangement you know for
the BBC chair to be appointed by the
government that's been true under
parties of of governments of both
political parties that's a long-standing
Arrangement and we don't have any plans
to change it I guess
that's
think that this whole Scandal came about
because the government under Boris
Johnson was trying to get their allies
into this job right so wouldn't the best
thing to do just to take all government
involvement out of the process going
forward well the BBC is funded
effectively by taxpayers not through
taxes but through the license fees so I
think it's important that the government
is involved in making the appointment
and British and that will clearly
continue to implement the rules that are
long-standing so we've got no plans to
change them and I said those are the
rules that have been implemented by
governments of both parties and I think
they've worked well over over time and
you've got an announcement on scams
today just tell us what the idea is yes
areas of crime fraud is one of the big
areas that targets people so what we're
doing is cracking down and banning cold
calling of people trying to Market
Financial products
um so that we can then be clear with
people that you know if you receive a
cold call trying to Market these things
uh it'll be from somebody who shouldn't
be doing it to try and give people that
confidence it's one of the areas that
where crime is growing we're seeing
crime falling violent crimes falling
neighborhood crime is falling fraud is
one of the areas people are targeting
and the government's being tough and
cracking down on it hence the
announcement today and just finally um
there's lots in the papers about the
coronation uh next weekend people
watching on TV are going to be asked to
pledge allegiance to King Charles as
well I don't know where you're going to
be on the coronation are you going to be
pledging Allegiance yes well of course
members of parliament pledge allegiance
to his majesty uh as part of swearing
and vote for office so I've already
pledged allegiance to the king very
happy to do so again and I hope people
do I think look coronation is going to
be a fantastic opportunity not just to
focus on our history and our
constitutional matters but also it's
it's a great showcase for Britain around
the world we're going to have hundreds
of foreign dignitaries coming here and
it's a great opportunity I think for
Britain to demonstrate all about our
country that's great our fantastic
values and we can all get the hide and
support
um his majesty the king okay thank you
very much thank you
morning uh you're watching the safe
Ridge on Sunday my interview's there
with the government and also of course
uh care starmer leader at the labor
party Lots about those uh strikes that
I'm sure we're going to impact so many
uh people over the next couple of days
and still to come on the program this
morning in just a few moments we are
going to be talking to the General
Secretary of the Royal College of
Nursing Pat Cullen so lots to talk to
her about plus a little bit later we
know of course those local elections
fast approaching we're going to be
hearing from the deputy leader of the
green party that is Zach Polansky
[Music]
thank you
well the Royal quality of nursing is
holding a fresh strike today but without
the exemptions that had previously been
in place for emergency cancer and other
types of Care Now RCN members rejected
the government's payoff that the union
leadership recommended and unions in the
house that are now split some have
rejected some have accepted and a
majority decision is going to be made on
Tuesday so a really really important
week ahead we can talk now to the
General Secretary of the Royal College
of Nursing Pat Cullen great to have you
on the show this morning I'm sure this
is going to be the number one priority
for so many of our viewers this morning
nurses from your union are shortly going
to be walking out what is the impact of
that strike going to be well clearly
there will be an impact of course there
will be
um but it's an impact that can
um be stopped by this government if they
get around the table again and start to
talk to me about the hundreds of
thousands of nurses that participated in
this ballot but leaving that aside I
want to just correct one thing that was
said by Mark Harper this morning around
the Royal College of Nursing not putting
in place National exemptions to make
sure that our patients are continued to
be treated safely during this period of
strike that's not true we have put
National exemptions in place and our
nurses as we have I've said time and
time again will never leave their
patients unsafe or create more risk
that's already in the system at this
point in time can we just clear this up
yes because I'm confused I'm honest I'm
totally confused about what exemptions
are in place and what aren't yes
previous strikes there have been
exemptions for emergency care right a e
cancer maternity and so on my
understanding was that
some hospitals will get exemptions Great
Ormond Street for example who have
raised concerns about Staffing levels
but not all so what is the truth what's
going on there are National exemptions
in place for a range of services for
emergency departments for intensive care
units for neonatal units Pediatric
Intensive Care units those really acute
urgent Services we have put National
exemptions in place we've worked
tirelessly with NHS England in fact it
was the Royal College of Nursing
contacted NHS England to ask for a
process to be put in place so that we
could make sure that this strike was
safe for our patients because that's not
what I thought right so what's going on
there is it changed or
look we issued our notices for 10 days
ago as I said we contacted NHS England
to work
um with them and alongside them to put a
process in place with that process in
place and those National exemptions have
been granted right up until last night
we were working on those and right
throughout the period of strike we will
continue to have an incident room within
the Royal College of Nursing headed up
by a very Senior Chief nurse that will
ensure that any exemptions that are
requested during that time are
considered carefully and on the clinical
basis that that they deserve are you
confident then that lives won't be put
at risk by this strike
well you'll heard me say time and time
again why are nurses going on strike
they're going on strike because patients
lives are being put at risk every single
day and why because we have tens of
thousands of vacant nursing posts so I
want to say something else to some of
the general managers that have toured
the studio speaking over today and other
days and what I would say to them is
think carefully about what they are
saying and none of those people I
believe have walked in the shoes of our
nursing staff and I would say to them as
well it's interesting that they've come
today to talk about the risk that's
posed as a result of our nurses taking
strike action for the very reason that
I've said because of the crisis within
the Health Service and I would ask them
for those other 364 days of the year
speak up for their nursing staff tell
what the risk is that they are carrying
every single day and I would also ask
for those general managers how many of
them have ever walked in the shoes of
our nursing staff off so instead of
coming out today against those nursing
staff come alongside them and don't try
to silence them you're talking about
general managers of hospitals yes I am
so you think you think that actually
they don't really understand what some
of their
hard-working nurses are doing well is
there a bit of a split I think I think
there has to be when you hear some of
the comments this morning from the chief
executive of NHS employers for example
talking about the risk that's posed on
the day of a strike and I would ask him
to step back and think why have nurses
taken this action after 106 years
because of the risk that they are
carrying every single day on behalf of
their patients so whilst the day of a
strike is important to the likes of the
NHS chief executive NHS employers chief
executive those other 364 days when the
burden of that risk is carried by our
nursing staff should also be important
and walk in the shoes of those nurses
and see what it's like look I can see
your passion right about the the service
that you represent
just put into one side though because
the question was about patient safety on
the strike days do you accept that
nurses going on strike does put patients
at risk
I accept that on days of strike that
services do not have the same level of
nursing staff and what they would have
on other days but again Sophie I go back
to those other 300 I understand it I
understand the point on that but I'm
just asking specifically it's
Inseparable it really is inseparable why
have our nursing staff been pushed to
the brink to take this action and lose
another day's pay on a day of a bank
holiday when actually they would get a
few extra points and they're willing to
take to take that they take to take that
on behalf of their patients and why
because they cannot continue on with the
level of risk that they're carrying it's
those people that sit at the bedside of
the patient and know that when they
leave they've left care undone simply
because there's not enough hours on the
day and these are selfless people
they're standing up for their patience
what I'd ask is for NHS employers and
this government to get behind them and I
think if we listen to the voice of
nursing we'll do the best thing for the
NHS and we'll certainly do the best
thing for those nurses now the
government's offered five pay deal
Unison have accepted it G and B have
accepted it why should the RCM be
different
well I believe that nursing is different
because nursing is the only profession
that stays alongside their patient 365
days a year 24 hours a day and they
believe that the short-term money that
was put into their pockets as a result
of this offer a non-consolidated it's
referred to it gives them money now but
it's taken back out at the end of the
year so what they were saying is it
might it might put a few points in my
pocket as an individual but it does
nothing to address the Recruitment and
Retention crisis that we've got of
nursing so get us back to that
selflessness bit about them not being
greedy as an individual but they're
wanting to address the long-term
problems within the Health Service what
I can't work out
is that you recommended this deal to
your members right
so you must have thought it was a decent
deal well
our ruling Council carefully considered
it along with myself and when you look
at the total package there were elements
of that package where actually
um worth worth putting to our members
and asking our members to consider
thought it was that bad you said if you
recommended it well look the money the
money was never going to actually be
what our nurses would have accepted it's
it's a it's hard why did you accept it
alone inflation because and I will
explain
there were issues there that we we
actually felt were worth looking at
around safer Staffing policy positions
which we feel would leave us in a better
position to have safer Staffing
legislation put in place and again
that's about nurses striking for the
Health Service and for their patients
not them as individuals and the other
element which has got a little bit
controversial with the other unions but
there's there's a rationale for this and
that is that we need to look at the pay
structure that Awards nursing staff and
why do we need to do that because the
current pay structure does not work for
nursing otherwise we wouldn't have the
retention and recruitment problems we've
got 62 percent of our nursing Workforce
sits in the lowest band within agenda
for Change and they don't enjoy some of
the other terms and conditions within
agenda for change that some of the other
professions do now this is not about
pitting ourselves against other
professional groups it's about asking
for nurses to be treated the same and
alongside those other professional
groups I've got to ask and you endorsed
a deal that ended up being rejected by
your members are you now feeling that
you have to slightly overcompensate to
kind of shore up your own position in
the union absolutely not uh I am in an
absolute privileged position to be able
to represent hundreds of thousands of
nursing staff I actually believe in them
it's a privilege to represent them they
have said loud and clear this deal is
not good enough it will not address the
issues that we're trying to address
within the Health Service and for me
it's not historic it is not a historic
payday in relation to the historic
action that they have taken I've heard
it described as fair and reasonable
there are fair things within the deal
but it doesn't go far enough and that's
why we need to get around the table
again and to start to address these
issues now on Tuesday of course the
health unions are meeting with ministers
to see if a majority of NHS workers
except the five percent deal and because
the biggest unions are backed it units
and GMB it's pretty likely it's going to
go through so you nurses will get the
five percent pay rise if that happens
what will you do then will you take the
money and still go on strike we'll still
encourage the Secretary of State to get
around a table with the Royal College of
Nursing if you look at the strike action
that has taken place today it has been
taken by nurses and the Royal College of
Nursing and it has been taken by those
nurses those hundreds of thousands of
nurses voted to take strike action after
106 years so we can't ignore the voice
of those people and if he continues to
do that and this government does we will
be rebalancing our members come the
mid-may close air mid mid June and that
means that we could Fair strike action
right up until Christmas period but
again I would urge the Secretary of
State Steve Barkley and this government
particularly the Prime Minister don't
push nurses to that position because
there's no there's no win for patients
out of this and it's wrong to do this
for for nursing staff okay thank you
very much indeed Pat Colin there of the
RCN explaining her position thank you
very much this morning now as usual what
the take is going to follow this program
just after 9 30 which is our chance to
analyze today's interviews talk through
any news lines I have to say there's
been an awful lot whether it's on
strikes or whether it's the pitch by
care starmer and we'll be joined then by
adaptive political editor Sam coats but
we can get a bit of a take from Sam now
on what stood out to him this morning uh
Sam what have you made of the interviews
last big interview by kirst armor before
the local elections on Thursday and I
thought the exchanges will actually uh
live on particularly those exchanges
about the attack ad not for the reason
that the government spokesman Mark
Harper said he said he regretted that
kistama had gone low just from the party
who's prime minister was using the
phrase sir softy so I think the public
will accept uh politicians do actually
go personal quite regularly no I thought
it was interesting because labor
strategists think that those attack ads
particularly the one uh attacking
rishi's tunak for failing to jail
rapists have been very important this
campaign because it's allowed them to
talk about what they say they want to
talk about and I think you saw over the
course of that interview actually for me
it was quite interesting the way that
KIA stammer was able to use the space
created by the conversation about the
attack ads to get quite a lot of his
points across I thought that he was
quite reasonable in his tone he stood by
Those ads adverts and he got the points
about the conservative record over
successive Prime Ministers across but I
think there's a problem in the interview
kirst armor made clear that he in the
same way took responsibility for
everything he did as the head of the
director of public prosecutions he said
he was there learning lessons when there
were failures and the problem is there
were some failures when he ran the DPP
could the Tories now use that exchange
to throw back at him some of the
decisions he made in his last job uh
really interesting Sam I think that does
perhaps open that up and it's difficult
as we say for labor to really say that
much about it as a result uh some coats
uh there now as we've been saying a lot
in the program there's now just four
days until a crucial set of local
elections across England it's a big test
for the main Party leaders but also for
the small parties too who tend to often
do quite well at local level including
the green party which is hoping it can
take overall control of a council for
the first time we're joined now by the
deputy leader of the green party
Polanski thank you for being uh with us
thanks for having me so I've got local
elections fast approaching where are
your main targets what's a good night
look like well there's literally
exciting opportunities for the green
party everywhere I've been whistling
around the country for the last few
weeks mid-suffolk is obviously the one
that I think a lot of people are paying
attention to we could have an outright
majority on mid-suffolk Council just to
be clear that would be the first time in
the northern hemisphere that the green
party had an outright majority on a
council so that would be a really big
night for us but also we're looking to
extend control places where we're
already in administration places like
Caster Lewis writing and Hove but
actually there's lots of other councils
too I was on the world yesterday this
week I've been in Bradford Sheffield but
also quite excited about Worcester
Hertfordshire herefordshire South
tyneside as you can hear there's lots of
them
um you say that the greens are targeting
everywhere but let's get real there's
some and you've rattled off a few of
them where you've got a real chance of
breaking through others where let's be
honest it's going to be a bit of an
uphill struggle in those areas do you
think that green supporter should vote
tactically I think what's really clear
is when people see green councilors they
want more green councilors so that's not
the question though no absolutely
tactically one though I think I would
always say if there is a green party
politician on the ballot paper then vote
for agreement because a vote for a green
is a vote for someone in your community
we don't necessarily have professional
politicians we have doctors nurses
cleaners people who are in their
communities who have got involved with
politics because they want to tackle
both the climate crisis and the cost of
living crisis and on Thursday by voting
green that's an opportunity to have a
real Community representative
in the local election week everyone's
getting their expectation management
game in right so we had Mark Harper
saying look the conservatives we're
going to lose around a thousand seats
and he had Kirsten say no they should be
making gains they shouldn't lose any
seats what's the truth there is a lot of
expectation might have been going on
watching those interviews so in 2019 uh
the green party had our best results
ever and then it's only ever got better
since then so this should technically be
a tough election for us because for the
very first time we're defending that big
surge of seats we had but actually not
only do we expect to hold those seats
we're looking to gain even 100 more so
you can call this expectation management
but actually I'm really hopeful and
excited for the green party's chances
right let's talk about policy a little
bit shall we um earlier this year you
stepped back from an outright rejection
of NATO now NATO is obviously a nuclear
Alliance what's the green party position
on nuclear weapons then well we're not
keen on nuclear weapons at all and I
think that shouldn't be a contentious
thing to say I think very often in
politics it's kind of driven that
politicians to ask would you hit the
nuclear button I think we need to be
really clear how devastating nuclear
weapons are so with NATO we are still
very skeptical and I think it's fair to
say that we're looking for reforms for
NATO so for instance they would say that
they would never use nuclear weapons
first that they would put dialogue over
military action and I think all of those
things have basic Common Sense things
that would appeal to most people I think
we need to be really clear and we see
this uh with Ukraine that a country's
Sovereign right to defend itself in
defense must absolutely be there that's
very different to militaristic
operations that are often baked in money
and about governments trying to accept
just to be clear then what is the stance
on nuclear weapons then because you no
one likes them right no one wants to use
them but some people think they're a
necessarily evil do you think they're
necessarily evil or do you think they
should be got rid of and if you think
that why are you not against NATO well
I'd like to see them get rid of and in
fact that is NATO's own policy so NATO
nuclear Alliance though isn't it come on
well exactly and that's why we're
looking to reform in in their own
nuclear Alliance they talk about a time
when they would never longer no longer
have to exist and I think that's the
place we have to get to I don't think
that's particularly complicated I think
we want to make sure we're looking for a
world where we're looking for peace and
security that's not naive I think what's
naive is to continue in an arms race and
expect that to bring peace I'm Keen to
ask us too as well high-speed uh rail
um
the green party position on high speed
Trail
so high speed rail is a more complicated
question because we absolutely support
High-Speed Rail now on hs2 on that
particular project I think that risk
turning Birmingham into a commuter town
for London there's actually large areas
of the north and particularly in Wales
that don't have any real infrastructure
at all so essentially what we're saying
is we've reached a point where 40 of
this has been built already so there
will be a point in time where we have to
say okay is it now time to reconsider
position at the moment we're looking to
hold hs2 limited to account to look how
can we minimize the risk of this but to
give you another example I'm elected in
the London assembly and I'm challenging
London Mercedes Khan he's building a new
road tunnel the Silvertown Road tunnel
that's going to cost 2.5 billion pounds
I've argued very strongly that that road
tunnel should not be built for both
social justice reasons air pollution is
a real killer particularly for minority
communities and the working class and
they often have the most toxic air the
mayor has insisted on building that
tunnel and now the diggers are in the
ground we've reached a point now where
it's no longer sensible to oppose it
we've got to talk about how can we
rescue it and get it um using public
transport instead just to go back to hs2
right because if you're serious about
green policies right we've got to invest
in Railways it's one of the Greener
methods of transport and this is the big
chance the big infrastructure project
and I get that people have issues with
hs2 that there are individual cases
things you'd like to do differently look
at the green party might be back here I
think it's bigger than people just have
issues on it it's incredibly
environmentally destructive there's lots
of ancient Woodlands that are being
destroyed and ultimately again it comes
back to the same question does
Birmingham to London really need that
new piece of Railway infrastructure or
did actually lots of places painting for
the rest of it saying look why don't you
we should be back backing hs2 it needs a
champion why don't you do that I'm
absolutely backing more Railway
infrastructure that's not
environmentally destructive I think it's
really important that we have proper
nuanced conversations about this so we
absolutely support high-speed Railway
well exactly if the project is not right
then it's right to challenge it rather
than just back it on ideological grounds
and just finally what's your green
guilty pleasure Unity sir do you take
like a flight every year every day yeah
what's that what is it well I'm really
going to bore you because I'm vegan I
don't fly and I don't drive but actually
my guilty pleasure is saying to people
all the time so you don't have to be
vegan to join the green party you can
own a car and be in the green party
ultimately this is about system change
and the big change we're not about
individual responsibilities so I'd
encourage everyone to join the green
party on greenparty.org forward slash
join wow
if you managed to sneak that one in I
didn't even have time to cut you off uh
thank you very much indeed of figurine
party
at where you can certainly see the local
elections uh hotting up it's going to be
fascinating uh this week lots of
coverage on Sky News I'm going to be
with you on Friday as well
now artificial intelligence you've
probably heard of it you probably know
it's going to have a big impact but what
exactly is it well you may also have
heard of chat GPT now I'm slightly
obsessed with this the AI chat bot that
with instruction can write things for
you now it's been criticized for writing
people's essays for them or even student
dissertations and there's also a concern
that it could replace many literacy jobs
in the future
or maybe you've seen images like this
created by AI which has recently become
viral along to with AI songs like Taylor
Swift singing Kanye West when she didn't
even sing the song these are all AI
images it is absolutely mind-blowing
or maybe you've seen this one someone
coming for my job this is what I'm
particularly worried about the AI
newsreader and presenter who was
unveiled in Kuwait recently
just looks quite impressive isn't she as
well and this stuff barely scratches the
surface and it's growing fast the value
of AI is expected to be over one and a
half trillion pounds in 2030 and that's
20 times what it is now and there are
concerns about the dangerousness of it
how dangerous it could potentially
become in the last few weeks over a
thousand Tech Giants including Elon Musk
and the Apple co-founder Steve Wozniak
have signed a letter to call for a halt
to the development of AI
well our next guest is Professor Stuart
Russell a British computer scientist
who's known for his contributions to AI
but he's also signed that letter and he
joins us now thank you so much for being
on the program uh with us it's really
fascinating can you just explain why you
decided to sign the letter
um so the letter asks for a pause in the
developmental release of systems that
are more powerful than gpt4 which is the
successor of chat gbt that you just
mentioned
um and the reason I signed it I should
say I didn't write it but I signed it
because I think it needs to be said that
we don't understand how these systems
work we don't know what they're capable
of and that means that we can't control
them we can't get them to behave
themselves
uh and they're already causing harm for
example uh there was a gentleman in
Belgium who committed suicide with the
advice and guidance of of a chatbot
um and people are concerned about
disinformation about uh racial uh gender
bias in the outputs of these systems
and we need time to develop the
regulations
uh that will
make sure that the systems are
beneficial to people rather than harmful
um
sorry go ahead so it's extraordinary to
to listen to you um it kind of feels
like the sort of thing that I read about
in science fiction novels you know 10
years ago 20 years ago
um what kind of examples can you give we
sort of showed some of them before like
deep fake songs and images but but what
kind of examples are you most concerned
about
so there's a distinction between the
systems that already exist
um and I think one of the biggest
concerns is disinformation and deep
fakes
um
we've had disinformation for a long time
right I mean propaganda and all that but
the difference here is I can now ask
gbt4 to read
all about Sophie ridges
social media presence everything Sophie
Regis ever said or written uh all about
Sophie rogers's friends
um and then
just begin a campaign gradually by
adjusting
your news feed maybe occasionally
sending some fake news along into your
news feed so that you're a little bit
less supportive of Ukraine
um and you start pushing harder on
politicians who say we should support
Ukraine in the war against Russia and so
on that'll be very easy to do
um and the really scary thing is that we
could do that to a million different
people before lunch
and so you can have a huge impact with
these systems uh for the worse by
manipulating people in ways that they
don't uh even realize is happening
genuinely really scary if I'm being
honest and to listen to that is that
kind of thing happening now
I would say quite likely yes
um there are we know in China and Russia
North Korea large teams of people who
pump out disinformation uh and we've
just given them a power tool
the concern of the letter is really
about the next generation of a system
um right now the systems I think have
some limitations in their ability to
construct complicated plans uh for
example you know if you wanted
plan for one company to take over
another that's a really complicated
thing and I don't think these systems
can generate those kinds of plans
successfully but
quite possible that the Next Generation
or the generation after could start to
do that and then you could see uh
corporations being run by AI systems uh
you could see uh military campaigns
being organized by AI systems and in the
long run the concern is quite a simple
one right if you're Building Systems
that are more powerful than human beings
how do human beings keep power over
those systems forever
uh that's the real concern behind the
open letter
wow really really big questions you're
talking about a pause so regulation can
catch up but you're also saying that
look countries like China and Russia can
use this
so in some ways what's the point of
Regulation when people are just going to
ignore it
so interestingly China just after the
open letter came out issued regulations
that are much stricter than anything
that the European Union is contemplating
or the United States for that matter
um and some people view the Chinese
regulations as a de facto ban on these
kinds of systems we call them the large
language models like chat GPT because
the Chinese rules for example say that
they may not output false information
uh and one of the things we know about
these large language models is that they
lie through their teeth all the time
without even realizing it
um they make stuff up
um
you know and uh
there's no way to control them right we
don't understand how they work inside we
don't understand what makes them uh say
things that aren't true and the only way
we have to control them is basically to
say bad dog
right bad dog and hope that by keeping
on saying bad dog they'll learn to
behave themselves better
um that's not a very reassuring method
of control or for systems that can
affect the lives of millions of people
my concern though is I accept that you
know it's really interesting to hear
about the regulations in China but there
will always be bad actors whether that's
Nations or whether that's individuals so
no matter how much regulation you put in
place can it ever really be safe
I think that's uh that's a really good
point and I've been trying to convince
governments of the need to start
planning ahead for
for the time when we need to actually
change the way our whole digital
ecosystem if you like the way it works
because right now
your computer pretty much runs anything
that people send to it unless it knows
already that it's malware right that it
knows that it's a virus because it has
it has a signature that it can recognize
we actually need to flip that around so
that your computer won't run anything
unless it knows that it's safe
um and if we have it working that way
then we can say okay AI systems that
don't come with a guarantee of safety uh
the system simply won't run them that's
a big change but I think it's something
that's going to be absolutely necessary
in the long run
what does it mean for jobs as well we
were joking about the newsreader well I
mean I was kind of joking about the news
um but there are big implications for
people's jobs
yeah so some studies suggest that
um these large language models like chat
gbt could affect uh maybe 300 million
jobs in the developed economies
um and I think they're also going to
have a big impact on all the Outsourcing
jobs
um that are helping to create a middle
class in in lots of other countries
around the world because Outsourcing
really means breaking jobs down into
small easily digestible pieces
um that people who are not super expert
can tackle and then send back the
results and it's exactly those kinds of
tasks that systems like chat GPT can do
very well they're actually extremely
good at writing computer programs for
example so many many programming jobs
could be lost
and there's a there's a kind of a mantra
going around that you'll hear from a lot
of the tech industry which says well
we're not going to replace humans we're
going to augment humans we're going to
make them more productive we're going to
give them more time to work on the
things that matter
um and I think this is just a mythical
argument because let's say you're a
radiologist right and maybe we can get
AI systems that take care of 80 of the
cases that are just routine
but people are not going to break their
legs in more interesting and complicated
ways just to keep Radiologists in work
right the obvious consequence is that uh
if Radiologists are much more productive
we will need fewer Radiologists
um and this is going to happen across
the board
societies need time to adjust
um and I'm a little bit worried that
governments are not really thinking
ahead uh about how those adjustments are
going to need to work in our education
system in the structure of our economy
many governments are thinking oh we'll
just retrain people to be data
scientists and robot Engineers but you
know we only need a few million of those
and there's a few billion people
whose livelihoods could be threatened by
systems coming in the future
wow I mean you say you're a little bit
worried I'm more than a little bit
worried after talking to you I will be
honest and it's been fascinating to talk
I could talk to you all morning and I'm
also been looking at the time where you
are as well uh half 39 minutes past one
in the morning in California so our
thanks for taking the time out to talk
to us we really appreciate it
very nice talking to you Sophie bye
oh wow what a fascinating uh guest
Stuart Russell uh well that is it for
this week's safer Ridge on Sunday in a
minute though after the break we're
going to be running through today's
interviews with our Deputy political
editor Sam Coates so much to talk about
this morning thank you for joining us
[Music]